runner goes and a stolen base for tommy
edmond that's one way to generate some
offense you have to and then
you know the first two games
one run you get a rain out you guys sit
back and start thinking about what's
going on great job right there great
jump not even close
and that brings up nolan aronado
and he hammers that out to deep left
that's how you snap the o for 20.
two-nothing cardinals are anato his 13th
home run
two-nothing st louis
well you know my philosophy on when you
struggle right what is it you stop
hitting you take a day off you back off
and a swing and a miss o'neill is down
on strikes and arenado's 13th home run
gives georgia native adam wainwright in
early lead 10th of the season
and a ground ball taken easily by paul
goldschmidt one inning in the books on
this father's day
and hits one in the air toward right and
right at ronald he will haul that in and
wilson recovers with a one two three
second inning two nothing cardinals just
underway in game one
you can see probably off speed right
here yadi alert in the third baseman
from his knees oh he got him what a
throw
yada year molina from his knees is there
anyone better really nobody
still doing it that's the second time
what this week from his knees
i'm sorry 1.98 seconds to get that ball
to second base second strikeout for adam
wainwright
carl shin uh base hit into left
[Applause]
on a zero on
count
and a diving stop at third by riley to
rob goldschmidt but they throw it away
tommy edmond racing to third
and pop warner will hold him up or
rather excuse me dylan carlson to third
after the throwing air by austin reilly
take advantage
in the air to center no carry to it hey
look hey you're a good guy you're a good
guy chip it's not no header
the 2-2 pitch curve ball
and a swing and a miss a pair of
strikeouts and four today for adam
wainwright we move to the fourth
look at that
absolute rocket off his back down into
the corner
extra bases for tyler o'neill
and we didn't even mention the sprint
speed he can absolutely fly you try to
get the hit but you try to advance the
runner at the same time maybe try to get
another run across the board up the
middle base hit o'neal
coming home
yachty
ties johnny bench with career hit number
2048
on a single to center field and the
cardinals lead 3-0
for adam wainwright here it is and it's
lifted to right acuna drifts back
and he has plenty of room to make the
play and that will retire the cardinals
they had a run
as this ball is smacked into right field
that's going to get down for a base hit
there's the first for the braves today
3-1 count last time got the curveball
this time got some love i think
varieties eliminate something inside
because he's trying to get you to roll
over on that sinker when he comes in
first pitch swing and a base hit for
ozzie freddie's going to cut the bag at
second he's on his way to third and the
braves will have the tying run come to
the plate with nobody out
that's a perfect job chip you get a
couple singles like that and at some
point
another one middle of the plate you
don't try to do too much
runner goes swing and a miss molina's
throw skips at second ball drop freeman
scores it's three to one
well great read by freddy
who was just a little bit off the back
but he saw the moment
molina let that ball go
freddy darted for home and even if
deyoung tries to cut this ball off
you see that he was gone and even if he
tried to scoop that there's no way he
gets freddie at home you don't see
hunter winterstadt miss too many pitches
right there like that
hit the third nolan ornato with the
plane over to goldie
so
back-to-back hits then back-to-back
strikeouts braves get on the board and
it's 3-1
1-2
and carlson hits it out to deep right
field at the wall and it's off the
bricks at the top
played perfectly and right by acuna it's
a double for dylan carlson second and
third and nobody out
a few feet away from a two-run homer
goldschmidt has hit one to the track
that was caught and an infield single
first pitch
out to deep right center
gone
three run homer
goldie on the first pitch he sees in the
fifth
busts it open for saint louis
goldschmidt is homer today also an
infield hit so bases loaded 1-0 pitch
here to paul goldsmith
rips it
into left field and a base hit
a run will score goldie has driven in
four of the seven today and the bases
remain loaded for nolan arenado somebody
needed a couple of afternoons off huh
and that'll be a bases loaded walk and
nolan is driven in three now he's
staying with his plan
it's a high fly ball into right
oculia back to make the catch on the
track
dylan carlson tags up
runner from second tacking up to third
and that makes it a 9-1 st louis lead
and a shot into shallow center ender is
there
and that will retire the side three runs
on two hits three walks and a sacrifice
fly adam wainwright in command
and if the braves are gonna go anywhere
they're gonna need him to do it
nine strikeouts for bueno
twice of freeman twice of acuna think
about that too
today it's been in sync and that is
strikeout number 10
for 39 year old adam wainwright
so i saw him in college and follow him
in the pros
a strikeout and he strikes out the side
and a season-high 11 strikeouts for adam
wainwright
the 2-1 pitch
and a fly ball
right center carlson has it bueno
seven innings against his former team
the team that drafted him
the team that he loved and he shuts down
the atlanta braves today in a game that
the cardinals needed 9-1 he gives him
seven
orinato
goldschmidt big days and the cardinals
take game one of the doubleheader